pues quizás la principal de esas
reformas es la reforma pensional y es
que va a ser digamos la gran lenin eran
digamos la gran reforma que él va a
tener que llevar a cabo que fue uno de
los puntos esenciales a lo largo de toda
esa batalla por las elecciones
presidenciales él ha hablado de pues de
la edad de pensión que debería pasar a
los 64 65 años y allí es donde hay
digamos una de las partes más
importantes de desacuerdo entre la
izquierda entre la derecha e incluso
entre las mismas derechas no están de
acuerdo en que esta edad que esta
jubilación pues pase a los 65 años
actualmente es de 62 algunos partidos
también han pedido que pase de hecho a
los 60 años y se tenga en cuenta también
todo lo que tiene que ver alrededor de
la pena habilidad debilidad del trabajo
de aquellos cargos de aquellos puestos
de trabajo en donde pues hay todo un
desgaste físico que debe también tenerse
en cuenta así que esa es la principal la
reforma que él pues va a llevar a cabo
en todo caso ese es en todo caso lo que
busca es era uno de sus puntos
principales de su programa presidencial
pero efectivamente ahora con estos
resultados el día de hoy esperar a lo
que pueda suceder dentro de ocho días
podría complicarse mucho para él en caso
de que sea la izquierda a la que se
quede con una amplia mayoría en la
asamblea nacional